When people communicate, they are often quite careless.
It's very easy to make a general statement about something that isn't really based on fact.
For example, all Americans have big noses or Korean mothers are the best.
Generalizations are general statements or opinions which are only partly true...
...because they are based on only a few examples or cases, or on incomplete knowledge.
These judgments may be made on the fly, represent conventional wisdom,...
...and feel intuitively right and yet still be wrong, offensive,...
...and downright dangerous.
Hasty generalizations made about others help to perpetuate stereotypes,...
...damage business relationships, and keep us from truly understanding the real world,...
...its people, and the relationships we share with others.
Smith, who is from England, decides to attend graduate school at Ohio State University.
On his first day in the U.S., he is walking around the university...
...and sees two albino squirrels chasing each other around a tree.
In his next letter home, he tells his family that all American squirrels are white.
Imagine seeing someone for the first time and thinking.
She's tall and beautiful, too. Maybe she's a model.
She's wearing Prada. I saw the movie "The Devil Wears Prada." She must be a bitch.
I won't talk to her first. She's smiling condescendingly at me.
She must think I'm unfashionable. She's saying hello kindly.
Oh, she's okay after all. Actually we don't know if she's nice or not.